okay
so hear me out I know this might sound
absolutely ridiculous but
I played around with it
and I actually think it's pretty cool
like I think it might actually be useful
so AI is a very controversial topic
these days everyone's talking about it
everyone's scared it'll take over the
world or it'll take over your job and I
mean to some degree
think I agree that might happen and I
know that there's gonna be like some
Cult of purists who will just refuse to
consume any media where AI had any part
in the creation of it there'll be like
products or works of art that are
certified AI free and that's fine I mean
there are people who only like analog
stuff like they'll only support movies
shot on film and they don't like digital
and that's also fine but it's pretty
crazy how all of a sudden AI has just
become so so prevalent and so competent
it seems or is it
I want to put it to the test a little
bit today a while ago I saw how Chach
ABT was being used to basically just
write code I think the very first thing
I personally saw along those lines was
someone use it to like generate a
blender script but I thought I would
give it a go and see if it could write
some C plus plus code for me and do like
a little code review on it and to see
like what that code was like like was
that was it acceptable code was it good
quality code could it actually be useful
to a c plus programmer to have it
generate code for you I mean when you
think about it it really makes sense
like it really does I think because
programming is such a mechanical thing
like
humans I think try to convert it into an
art form like people will actively try
their best to make the code look clean
really easy to read like the beauty of
the actual code you know it almost
becomes like a poem written by a poet
like you want the code to look nice and
that does have some Merit right because
obviously humans are the ones who are
going to be reading and writing that
code so it makes sense to make it more
aesthetic for them to make it more kind
of simple and easy to understand and
maintain like that's to the benefit of
the product as a whole but but when it
comes down to executing the code
does the computer care about that no and
often this art form of programming will
actually be detrimental to the program
to the software because all of this
abstraction that goes on top of it can
actually hurt the performance of the
code and not only that but we as humans
like you know we're not computers like
we write bugs all the time we can not be
careful and wind up with a memory leak
or something so in a way if you think
about it if I could write code
mechanically to be optimized for you
know a given architecture a given CPU or
whatever Hardware I'm executing it on
and I could make sure that I obviously
didn't write any memory leaks or bugs
because I am a mechanical being wouldn't
that be a good thing hi I wonder who's
good at that
AI if we can tell a really highly
trained AI model to write some code for
me generate me some code that I don't
know does this that creates a data
structure like a resizable array it's
not going to make the same mistakes that
a student probably would in University
trying to replicate that like where they
forget to free some memory or maybe
They're copying a string and they forget
about the null termination character and
suddenly that could cause a problem down
the road like that stuff just wouldn't
happen and not only can the AI generate
you basically perfect code that is bug
free and leak free it also understands
context once it's written the first
version for you you can ask it to change
some stuff up to fix some stuff up and
it also seems to actually understand how
the code works and why it does what it
does you can literally ask it just in
English to please explain to me what is
this thing I don't understand this thing
or can you just go through and just flat
out annotate every single line of code
with a comment that explains how it
works like I'm not kidding it's it's
pretty wild and I honestly think there's
so many use cases for it where maybe you
just need to quickly write an algorithm
why waste your time doing that yourself
manually and in a possibly imperfect
bug-filled way when you could just get
AI to generate that code snippet for you
like it just makes so much sense and if
you feel threatened by that then I'm
sorry anyway all these examples that I
just talked about like with the
resizable array we're going to take a
look at that today I'm going to show you
my experience with AI and C plus plus
now while we're on the topic of AI and
how useful it can be let me tell you
about the sponsor of today's video
grammarly go grammarly go provides you
with personalized generative AI
communication assistants that can really
help you with your productivity now one
of the coolest features of grammarly go
is the fact that you can set a voice you
can specify like a tone or a style of
how you want the generated text to sound
and so if I'm trying to generate some
text for like a game that I'm making and
I want some kind of I don't know
emergency announcement to take place for
the evacuation of a ship or something I
can tell it how I want it to sound I can
say that I want it to sound like formal
for example and then just tell it hey
generate me some emergency evacuation
announcement but again using the power
of AI I can come back to that and be
like well no I mean this part needs to
be a bit different there are no
elevators here let's talk about
lifeboats instead aside from just flat
out generating text another really
really useful use case is to take pieces
of text you've already generated so for
example we have a bunch of stuff here in
our Hazel documentation for our game
engine and we can just plug this into
grammarly and get grammarly go to like
rewrite and improve sections of that
text that we've already written to make
it sound a particular way so for example
this like opening statement here I want
it to sound a little bit more formal
maybe a bit more Stern a bit more
assertive I can tell grammarly go to do
that and as you can see it will rewrite
the text and make it sound the way that
I want it to sound and you know as
someone who has to write documentation
for my game engine from time to time and
I don't want to spend time on that
really I'd rather be writing the code
for the game engine but the
documentation just needs to exist and so
instead of having to think about how on
Earth am I going to phrase this I can
get grammarly go to help me out and save
me time there are lots of other exciting
features to check out you'll be amazed
what you can achieve with grammarly go
you can sign up using my link in
description below grammarly.com Cherno
and you'll get 20 off grammarly premium
you huge thank you to Grandma Lee for
sponsoring this video okay now that it's
nightfall
um
hi wow well that took like that took
like 10 seconds to generate for some
reason do you know any C plus plus oh
excellent because I have an assignment
Drew like yesterday
um all right all right all right
how do I make a resizable array let's
start with that let's pretend that we're
trying to like do some some assignment
that is that has told us to like write a
resizable array all right so it's
generating some codes pretty quick not
gonna lie this is kind of interesting
what it's doing because like as far as I
can see this is just all in the main
function right and look it's gonna
explain everything in this example okay
let's start at the beginning in C plus
plus you can create a resizable array so
this is the prompt right how do I make a
resizable array in C plus plus and you
can see that I said do you know any C
plus plus and so because I said that it
has the context to know that when I say
how do I make a resizable rate I'm
talking about C plus plus so that's
pretty cool you can create a resizable
array using dynamic memory allocation
here's an example of how you can create
a sizable array okay so what it's done
is it's actually written me a full-on
program like let's copy this code just
before we continue
I've got a I've got a fresh Visual
Studio project here ai.cpp let's just
complete blank file paste it in let's
see like if this compiles because it
prints stuff as well I'm just going to
hit F5 okay so it's definitely printed
some stuff I don't see any anything
crashing like it full on just gave me an
example now at this stage of course you
could have just gotten that example from
a website that had that example but the
power I guess comes from the fact that
we can ask it to tweak this code if we
want so let's first of all read through
it and see how good of a job it did so
we have this array of size five again
extremely arbitrary this is probably not
what your assignment would want you to
do the size is five which we're kind of
manually keeping track of and there's
also a capacity of five you can see it's
actually added comments without even me
again the only thing I prompted was this
it's adding comments that explain every
line of code populate the array with
some values here it is just randomly
generating some values I plus one so the
first one will be like one two three
four five that's why we see printed over
here this decided to print it along with
a space could have used used a Char for
this instead of an entire string because
it's just one character interesting that
it chose not to increase the size of the
array so if size equals capacity okay so
interestingly enough it's
in this example it's created an array
deliberately of size 5 added five
elements to it over here and then of
course size is going to be equal to
capacity because it's done that here
deliberately which is actually kind of
interesting so then it doubles the
capacity over here right so we go from
five to ten uh it Loops through copies
every item deletes the old array
replaces this with the temporary thing
that we allocated which is no longer
temporary because now it's the main
array
um and then we also make sure to set
capacity so size hasn't changed because
we still have five elements but the
capacity is doubled now so we can add
five more things and we start at size
which is this is like it's really
interesting it's almost blowing my mind
how like this is a specific example I
wonder if this exists somewhere on the
Internet it's just like pulled something
off the internet like this is actually
someone's example on a blog post or
something like that I don't know I'm not
going to Google it and try and find out
but it's just interesting because it's
such a specific example right like this
is like this is in a way demonstrating
how resizable rate could work but it's
completely useless because it's not like
it's not like you can actually use this
code it's not like it's packaged it into
a class or something that you can just
reuse it's just kind of just been like
this is like all the different things
that are Dynamic array or a resizable
array could do and here like here they
are individually and here's like almost
a test that proves that it works which
is interesting I mean I did to be fair
like I did ask how do I make a resizable
right I didn't tell it make me one that
I can actually use for my assignment
please it was more like how does it
almost work because what I was asking
and then it explains that it creates an
array of size 5 populates it checks to
see if the size is equal to capacity if
it is create a new way so this is
interesting because it's kind of like
but why are you doing this like this
isn't really necessary this is just you
explaining your code but like in a very
like fine-grained way it's kind of like
then we check this if size is equal to
capacity which that doesn't really need
to be explained what would have been
better was probably to explain but why
are you doing this in the first place
and really it's just to prove that we
say sizing works I guess we then add
miles finally we print the memory
allocated okay uh can you put this
functionality into a class
let's see what it does here
so resizable array class in C plus plus
Okay cool so we have a class called
resizable array now okay so then we have
capacity interesting that it wrote cap
here and not capacity I guess it didn't
want to confuse the two capacities
so it shows cap but that's kind of
interesting so initializes it with a
capacity so you have to provide a
capacity here when you use this it's got
a pushback function much like the
standard template Library oh yeah it's
also using integers so this is an array
of integers and integers only um I guess
enter is kind of like the default type
means C plus plus I don't actually I
don't know if that's more of a c thing
but like if it can't find certain types
in select assumed so it's maybe that has
something to do with why it just
happened to choose that out of all
things it could have but it also provide
an example I was about to ask it to give
me an example of it using it but check
this out we have a resizable array five
elements again five it shows this time
you can see the functionality for
resizing is actually inside what it
wrote so pushback will resize which
means that it doesn't have to do it here
it can just make the array of five but
then try and add 10 and that will just
work and then we can go through all the
elements and print it
um which yeah it's pretty cool returns
zero which we don't actually need by the
way AI but yeah that's interesting and
then it kind of explains it which we'll
skip over okay not bad not bad but I
like I don't want to just use it with
ins I want to use it with every type
so maybe like can you make this into a
template of class so I can use it with
any type
let's ask it to do that and as you can
see it's generating us a templated
version that uses T instead of int so
this is kind of like this is the thing
that's really cool the fact that you can
kind of talk to this thing and be like
that's 90 of the way there but actually
tweak this one thing right and actually
what I'm noticing here is that it's not
really like it doesn't have comments my
University Professor wants comments so
one of the things I'm going to ask it is
basically it's still generating but I'll
just be like can you please because I'm
a nice person annotate the code with
comments
um I guess I'll wait wait for it to
finish generating here it's like
explaining everything this is I can this
is totally useful because the thing is
like you know it explains everything so
I I'm I'm assuming that like if you have
questions you know like if I had a
specific question like why are you
why are you doing like why are you
doubling the capacity actually that's a
nice question why are you specifically
doubling it because the standard
template Library I think by default will
add 50 to it so like it'll take half the
capacity and add that uh I don't know if
that's just like if that's all the
compilers do that like for you know JCC
mspc clang but uh yeah I don't know um
okay get the same codes before but you
can see now we have comments now we have
comments on every single line of code
that tells us what it does right and
there's even a copy code button like
they've made this too easy let's just
paste this in now right of course
everything compiles I didn't seem to
copy everything it's still generating
that's why I haven't finished all right
let's copy that again I was too quick
you got to wait you gotta wait man
unless you have chat GPT Plus or two
string is undefined bro you forgot to
include string ah F that's an F all
right let's run this yeah I mean like
it's here element one element two like
yeah it's printing stuff it's working
it's not crashing or anything okay so
let me just ask it like why are you
doubling the capacity uh when a resize
is necessary can you add 50
instead let's see what it does here
doubling capacity is a common strategy
is it who does that though I don't I've
never seen a library that does that yeah
like what it would use more memory if
you do this like you won't have to do it
as often though is also a valid strategy
so change the code to increase capacity
by 50 percent
because I that's one of the requirements
of my University assignment so let's see
so look when our resize is necessary
that's the language I used I said when I
resize is necessary so it's kind of
mimicking what I'm saying which is
really interesting because I I feel like
that itself would be helpful to people
just because it's echoing back some of
the stuff that you say which I feel like
would make the student kind of
understand or the program understand you
know what it's saying more because it's
using similar language it's kind of like
you know it's it's like when you when a
friend comes over and you adopt a little
bit of their Style just like
specifically with that friend
um and that's what I feel like is
happening here which is yeah a nice
touch I guess all right so let's see
what happens here with the size yeah
there it is new capacity capacity Plus
capacity divided by two that's what I'm
used to seeing so that's just amazing
just just like hey man can you change
this thing now obviously like this is
just like I mean you can go in by
yourself if you understand anything at
all and be like you know instead of
times two let me just do well that plus
you know plus capacity divided by two
because that's kind of what it's done
but like you know the fact that you can
just tell it like hey can you please do
that for me is amazing now if I had to
code review this code like I mean you
know me I'd I would change a bunch of
stuff I wouldn't have the private
members up the top I'd have them down
the bottom uh it's a bit weird that you
have to take in a capacity like why
can't I just decide on a capacity but
I'm sure you could just keep asking it
like hey I don't want to take in a
capacity choose a sensible default using
namespacity I definitely wouldn't use in
fact like why did you use that let's ask
like why it did that and like the thing
is you can see that it explains it like
because it didn't leave me a comment so
I don't know what this does if I'm a
student or I don't understand I've never
seen this before like why what does that
do I can ask it what it does and it
literally will be like example instead
of doing that then you can do that
instead now however it is generally
considered bad practice to use using
namespace to see okay in header files I
was going to say if it just says in
general that's funny that it's used it
um because it can cause naming conflicts
with other libraries or your own code
yes I agree I have a video called why I
don't using NATO sscd that's an old one
it's a blast from the past but you can
check it out up there but in small
programs or scripts it's generally
acceptable
um so let me just say so if it's bad
practice why have you used it now of
course it did say it's bad practice in a
header file that wasn't a hair file but
I just want to see what it says why have
you used it
um as an AI language model I've used it
in the code exams prior for the sake of
brevity and readability yep that I mean
that that's a good answer however in
actual code development generally
recommended to avoid it again it repeats
itself in header files or in large code
bases can you change your code to not
have it then because I want to become a
better C plus programmer and build good
habits certainly he's the same code
without the username they said so it's
removed it
um Dynamic wait did it change the name
was it
it was a resizable array now it's
Dynamic array why did it do that
whoa it completely changed everything
look now we have M underscore wait is
that because oh bro the private stuff is
at the bottom
did it just read my mind I didn't tell
it
I didn't tell it to do that
what is that because I was claiming it
was bad practice and I want to become a
better C plus programmer so it literally
implemented like better saver plus
programming like by having private at
the bottom and using M underscore for
like members for private members holy
smokes I did not expect that and it does
capacity times 1.5 and then look resize
resize has now become its own function
so okay I'm seeing two things here right
either it was like I need a copy of a
resizable Lottery data structure without
this so let me look at my database of
like examples that I have learned from
and just pick up another one that just
happens to not have that either it's
done that and it's just like you know
selected a different like you know
template almost of a dynamic array data
structure or it's actually just gone in
and improved the code because this is
obviously a better written like you know
data structure like a better written
class I guess than what we kind of saw
before but that is wild all I did was
ask it to do that oh I really wish I
could like if I wait can I go back
what does this do I almost kind of wanna
what if I do regenerate response okay
there's resizable array again and
there's private up the top and that's
that's the old class but now obviously
it's you know STD there's no using sscv
so it has to do STD everywhere huh
that's really interesting so that's
actually what I basically asked for but
I just wonder if it was like if it truly
and it gives me an example of different
types of sport which is cool I wonder if
it was truly like trying to improve the
programming like without me even asking
because I said some stuff like that
fun ah can you
write this class more professionally
like a real software engineer would now
that's very very subjective obviously
but I'm just wondering like what it
would do okay it has some some best
practices and design patterns private
self-top buddy are now it's using size T
and now it's got underscore see the
thing is like obviously like there's no
right way to write C plus plus there's
all of these oh man this is a completely
different class
wow we'll get into this in a minute but
like there's obviously no correct way
like especially when it comes to
subjective things like private I like to
have at the bottom you know I like to
use am underscore which it kind of like
it almost gave me the class I wanted
which is very suspicious but here it's
got like an underscore after which is
really weird which just kind of makes it
you know be different so it can do like
capacity underscore capacity without
having to do like this dot or this Arrow
capacity equals capacity or whatever if
the names are the same but I would just
use M underscore obviously
um but like let's take a look at what
it's done I might copy this into visual
studio so we can actually do a proper
code review but like this is um and of
course it explains why it's done this
thing it's not a default argument with
capacity it's changed these to be size
T's instead which uh is you know the
typist by The Sound Library that's true
uh rename the data members to use an
underscore suffix suffix interesting way
up here for improved readability uh
that's improved readability in the sense
that you can tell that it's a member but
again I would use a underscore
personally added a copy construct and
copy assignment that's good and change
the get method to use that operator for
accessing element so made the method
const to indicate
and we're out of gas apparently but
anyway let's take this code uh and let's
do a little code review and let's say
okay I don't get any compilers this time
got some stuff here okay so yeah again I
would put this let's rewrite this how I
would maybe as I'm doing the code review
let's kind of make this
be at the bottom uh I won't I won't
bother with the variable names I I don't
know if I would you I personally would
just use size T like that but that's
because like you know these headers that
I use like in msvc they decl they
actually have that I'm not sure if that
would apply to all compilers on all
platforms maybe that's why it's chosen
to do this okay so we have new T
capacity so that gets allocated there
it's made the Constructor explicit which
means you can't just you know be like
resizable array I didn't to generate
yeah you can't basically be like that
equals five like that because it's
explicit if I remove explicit then you
can see that's that's possible so it in
other words they've added that just to
make it like less likely that you'll
accidentally you know do an implicit
conversion from an integer into an
entire resizable array which could
happen then we have a copy Constructor
we don't have any move like we don't
have a move Constructor uh but that's
okay there's our Destructor
um yeah that's pretty standard like it's
using a city copy here to copy and then
we've got yeah so I mean it's just it's
just changed up the variable names this
is like all correct pretty standard
boilerplate it's interesting that it's
not dropping these guys onto a new line
um different code conventions obviously
different rule sets like well yeah have
different rules resize
um yeah so it's it's changed capacity
Plus capacity divided by two to 1.5
times capacity which is also fine
although that involves using a double
which I mean eventually gets downcast to
a to a un64t basically but I don't know
if I would do that over but then you
have an integer Division I don't know
whatever either way it's fine
um yeah resize okay it's even added
exceptions maybe that's part of the
being more professional as well we
actually have the ability to kind of
debug in a way um because if we're out
of range it won't just crash or have a
memory access violation it'll actually
throw an out of range exception size
return size we've got the cons there
which is good capacity and yeah no I
mean that's a pretty clean class like
yeah I don't know like this just looks
like a standard class like you couldn't
really tell obviously this is generated
by AI or anything like that it just
looks like a normal class so yeah no man
this is this is like this is fascinating
I really want to keep digging into this
if you guys want to see more AI videos
with C plus plus like let me know
suggest some topics in the comments
below because I don't know I might keep
playing around with this to be honest
it's really really fascinating hope you
guys enjoyed the video if you did don't
forget to hit the like button don't
forget to check out grammarly.com link
will be in description below and I will
see you next time goodbye